[Music]
mmm Lucroy fizzy cold refreshing and
incredibly addicting it starts with just
one candidate and then before you know
it this happens you're not alone either
sales of Lacroix have more than tripled
in the past few years but hey what's the
harm after all it's just water right it
says right here naturally flavored with
no sweeteners no calories no artificial
anything but if you're drinking a pack a
day you got to wonder what the hell is
natural flavor and could this stuff
actually be bad for you according to the
FDA natural flavor can be anything a
company uses to add flavor to a product
so long as it comes directly from a
natural source but there is a catch even
if for example a certain grapefruit
flavor is extracted directly from
grapefruits companies can still mix in
synthetic additives like solvents to
make that flavor blend well with the
other ingredients
the FDA calls these ingredients
incidental additives and thanks to a
lack of policy governing their use food
makers are not required to disclose what
they are or when they're in a product
when a consumer sees natural flavors on
an ingredient label that does not
necessarily mean that the product or
that or the food is free of synthetic
ingredients in higher concentrations we
definitely know that some of these can
be harmful the question would be at what
levels they're found in foods
so we asked national beverage if they
use any incidental additives in their
product Lefroy and no surprise they
claim that there is nothing artificial
in the drink of course we have to take
this claim at face value because they're
not required to tell us how they extract
those flavors there's two different
issues one is the lack of transparency
and not knowing exactly what's being
added to a product the other concern
would be that the use of these flavors
are making foods that may not be
is healthy for you as your body thinks
even if there's nothing artificial added
there could still be naturally derived
additives that could be harmful if you
drink too much of them
unlikely yes but there's no way to know
for sure and there's still one more
concern for Lacroix fanatics all those
bubbles so we asked a dentist is
carbonation bad for your teeth
packing water is carbon dioxide
dissolved in water which forms carbonic
acid when you drink a carbonated
beverage that natural fluid in the mouth
neutralizes the carbonic acid and is
very little damage likely to occur how
should you celebrate that bit of good
news with some bubbly of course but as
always drink responsibly
[Music]